after the Civil War there were enormous
changes in American life with
industrialization urbanization and
immigration changing the composition of
who lived in the United States where
they lived and what they did for a
living but city living and factory work
came with new social problems like
poverty and unsafe working and living
conditions the rise of big business had
also led to practices that limited
competition like monopolies and
price-fixing starting in the 1890s a
number of reformers began to advocate
for remedies to these social problems
they were known as the progressives and
this era of reform which lasted through
the 1920s has come to be known as the
Progressive Era but the difficult thing
about the Progressive Era was that these
reformers worked on all sorts of
different things
there were muckrakers which were
journalists writers and photographers
who tried to expose corruption or
unsanitary factory practices there are
politicians who tried to rein in big
businesses and protect consumers there
were conservationists who tried to
preserve national parks and wilderness
from exploitation and there were many
influential female reformers who tried
to help women children and immigrants
achieve better working and living
conditions so clearly progressives
didn't all share the same goals or
advocate for the same solutions to
problems how can we even compare the
goals and effects of the progressive
reformers when they were so diverse
let's start by taking a look at some of
the goals and achievements of the
progressives now I'm not going to go
into a lot of detail about individual
reformers or pieces of legislation here
what I'm interested in doing is taking a
bird's-eye view of the kinds of reforms
that progressives pursued during this
time period
first there were those who advocated for
sanitation and consumer protections like
Upton Sinclair whose novel the jungle
exposed the unsanitary conditions and
factories that made food products the
outrage that book generated led to the
passage of laws like the Pure Food and
Drug Act of 1906 then there were the
progressives who fought
or protections for workers they pushed
for an eight-hour workday and for safer
conditions for workers along with the
right for workers to bargain
collectively through unions along with
those reforms were others aimed at
advancing the rights of women and
children including limiting child labor
promoting access to birth control and
granting women the right to vote through
the 19th amendment many of the
progressive reformers were interested in
reining in the excesses of big business
politicians like President Teddy
Roosevelt went after trusts and
monopolies for stifling competition and
fixing prices another avenue of reform
was aimed at limiting political
corruption particularly city political
machines that were dominated by party
bosses one victory in this arena was the
passage of the 17th amendment which
provided for the popular election of
senators lastly there was a push for
moral reform to make society more
orderly and humane the major achievement
of these reformers was the passage of
the 18th amendment which prohibited the
sale or consumption of alcohol ok so now
that we've done a brief survey of what
the progressives were up to let's think
about what aspects these reformers had
in common with each other and where they
differed with or contradicted each other
so this might sound a little obvious but
one thing that United the progressives
was that they believed in progress but
is they thought it was possible to
improve society and to make people
better human beings this is worth
mentioning just because not everyone
felt that this was possible many of the
opponents of the progressives saw human
nature as fixed and a society with vast
inequalities of wealth and opportunity
as just an inevitable consequence of
industrialization a second shared belief
was that it was the role of government
to step in and fix these social problems
this was a big departure from the lays a
fair or hands-off approach of the Gilded
Age in that era attempting to improve
sanitation or morality would have been
considered work for private charities or
voluntary associations to take on but
the progressives thought that the
problems they were trying to solve were
too big for that approach
and they sought out the help of local
state and federal government to
implement their measures the campaign
for laws and constitutional amendments
to bring about change so they really
began a debate over whether or to what
extent the government should take an
active role in the welfare of its
citizens that would continue into the
Great Depression but the progressive
movement was also riddled with divisions
and internal contradictions one of these
was around voting rights the
progressives expanded democracy by
winning the right to vote for women but
they also advocated for restricting the
vote to who they considered good voters
white educated native-born people they
worked to impose literacy tests and
residency requirements in the north and
made no effort to challenge Jim Crow
laws preventing african-americans from
voting in the south progressives were
also divided on the issue of immigration
although a few progressives championed
the rights of immigrants and respect for
immigrants culture like whole-house
founder Jane Addams most progressives
thought the only way forward for
immigrants was complete assimilation
into American culture they also
supported restrictions on the entry of
immigrants they considered undesirable
like those from Southern and Eastern
Europe Asia and Mexico these beliefs
around who was fit to vote or to be an
American citizen derived from the flawed
racial science of the day which
categorized white anglo-saxons is the
most evolved race and everyone else
falling somewhere along a continuum of
less evolved people's with the exception
of African American activists like Ida B
Wells progressive reformers supported
segregation and pretty much turned a
blind eye towards the working and living
conditions of African Americans some
progressives even advocated eugenics a
plan to improve the American gene pool
by encouraging native white women to
have more babies and discouraging
undesirables from reproducing sometimes
through forced sterilizations so taking
these uniting and dividing factors into
consideration what conclusions can we
come to about the goals and effects of
progressive reform movement well I think
it's safe to say that the progressives
wanted to improve society and find a
remedy for the social problems caused by
industrialization and urbanization and
that they wanted to do so through
government intervention but their goals
were also limited they only wanted these
improvements for those they deemed
worthy to participate in American
society as for how effective their
reforms were at solving the problems of
industrialization and urbanization well
they did succeed in curbing some of the
worst problems of corruption sanitation
and exploitation but we would also need
to look ahead to the 20s and 30s to see
how much things really changed spoiler
alert this booming era of industry was
about to end with a crash